[Musique]
et le pape de solidarité territoriale
c'est de faire en sorte que nos
départements sur la cape de petits
moyens et bien combien disposition des
maires de france que vous monsieur le
maire
et vous mesdames et messieurs les élus
des conseils municipaux
le président du département rappelle
l'engagement du pacte de solidarité
territoriale
le maire du tampon andré thien ah koon
signe donc le pacte de solidarité
territoriale de sa commune avec le
départements une enveloppe de 4 millions
d'euros sera alloué pour les projets
d'investissement et neuf cent mille
euros pour les projets d'action sociale
encore mieux à la potomanie s'agit pas
de rêve le savons nous sommes des femmes
les jeunes qui lui tous les joueurs pour
leur survie soit dans le métier sur pour
trouver un emploi qui ont des graves
difficultés et nous devons tous se
mettre la main ensemble pour travailler
pour que notre population sur moi
malheureuse quatre grands chantiers
d'aménagement du territoire seront
principalement soutenu la potabilisation
de l'eau
la création du parc du volcan et d'une
filière équine la construction d'un
centre administratif pour le sud de
l'île et cette future route des eaux
entre la ligne decker est le 17e nous
allons participer au développement
agricole de toute une zone de poids de
4000 hectares sur le temps pompe
par le passé il ya des routes ont été
construites mais on a oublié de
désenclaver cette zone agricole et bien
le département va participer au
financement
4000 hectares des zones agricoles
ce sont des producteurs de l'ananas pays
des cultures maraîchères et fruitières
donc tout un pan de l'agriculture du
tampon qui pourra encore plus se
développer grâce à son désenclavement
c'est ça que je souhaite mettre en avant
sa division de l'aménagement du
territoire et le département accompagne
les maires qui ont cette vision 5 km de
routes traverseront c'est ravine des
eaux de l'île un projet structurant de
désenclavement des eaux qui développera
toute une partie de ces territoires
[Musique]